what's up guys bang bang
i keep hearing all this talk about
bitcoin mining but nobody's actually
serious when they're talking about it
they're uninformed so here's the real
information one bitcoin uses a fraction
of the world's energy for securing the
network bitcoin literally uses less than
one tenth of one percent of the global
energy on top of that most of the miners
over 70 percent of miners use some mix
of renewable energy but all that doesn't
matter if people in the climate change
community or in the energy community are
really serious about making a difference
about saving the planet etc the
conversation's got to be around nuclear
power nuclear power's got a really bad
name in the mainstream media or in
public opinion but if you actually go
and you look at it it is the lowest cost
safest most persistent energy source
that we have if we want to have true
power that puts the world in a better
place and allows people to constantly be
able to count on it than we need to
usher in an era of nuclear power now
nuclear power also can be used for
bitcoin mining bitcoin is agnostic to
what the energy source is whether it is
wind or solar or geothermal or nuclear
or coal bitcoin doesn't care all it's
looking for is energy to convert into
financial value now on top of that what
we see is there's already a push as
china went ahead and they banned bitcoin
mining in the country
people rushed into america the state of
texas the capital of oil and gas is
beginning to get absolutely crazy
everyone in the oil and gas industry
realizes that the most valuable use of
their energy is to mine bitcoins to
secure the decentralized digital open
monetary network it is the strongest
computer network in the world and
bitcoin miners around the world in the
last 24 hours made almost 50 million
50 million dollars a day right now is
being paid to bitcoin miners to secure
that network and so what we've got is a
choice are we going to continue to yell
and scream about the climate about
bitcoin mining and all this other stuff
or are we going to get serious are we
going to roll up our sleeves and get to
work if we're serious there's two main
uses that we should go after one gas
flare capture one of the biggest
problems to the economy one of the most
hurtful things to the economy is that
gas flaring it releases all sorts of
toxic shed into the atmosphere and it
destroys the planet so let's go capture
let's gas player capture then use that
for energy to mine bitcoin the second
one is nuclear power let's usher in a
brand new era of nuclear power and what
we will have is with bitcoin mining they
not only can set up immediately as peru
recently put in a brand new piece that i
wrote about this morning not only can we
use the bitcoin miners to be the first
customers but also they can be the
buyers of last resort of that nuclear
power it basically guarantees that the
nuclear power producers will end up
being profitable they will have
persistent demand for that power so
we're real serious about bitcoin mining
and we're real serious about the climate
what we should allow is the economic
incentives of the bitcoin network to
take over allow people to go build
nuclear power
and to use the bitcoin mining demand
for that power to be able to create
profitable environmentally friendly
businesses nuclear power is the future
bitcoin is the future as well when you
put those two things together it is
absolute rocket fuel for both industries
that's why you see all the oil and gas
folks becoming so interested in this the
best way to monetize their power is to
mine bitcoin the best way for bitcoin
miners to actually get access to power
at a cheap cost is go find a waste
stream like flarecast to actually use
and convert it into bitcoin mining this
is where the world's going if you're
serious about nuclear power if you're
serious about bitcoin i'd love to hear
from you if you know of anyone working
on nuclear power and bitcoin mining
leave a comment make sure you like the
video also make sure you subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you guys
tomorrow